JOHN DONHAM: TuneIn
lets you listen
to live audio from
around the world.
So you can think about
what it's like listening
to your radio in the car.
You have about 70 different
options, local radio stations.
TuneIn turns your mobile
phone into a radio
that can pick up
100,000 stations
from all over the world.
I think the first time we
turned on push notifications.
So we were able to tell our
audience for the first time
something live
happening right now.
And that was a big
surprise, because we
were wondering if
every one would care.
I think we used it for the
World Series, actually.
And so, the first time
we turned that on, it
was a huge surprise at the
sheer number of people that
didn't know that event was
going on at this moment and then
would click on
something and come in.
And so we saw a huge
traffic spike, as a result.
And now its part of every day.
You pick the things that
you're interested in.
When you pick things
like news or sports,
we just inform you
what's going on.
We're in 55
different car models.
We're in things like
connected speakers,
like Sonos or Samsung.
We're in connected televisions
like Samsung or with Google,
with Google TV.
And so in total, those
200 different platforms
are a big product challenge,
because how do you
design a consistent experience
when sometimes there's
no screen and sometimes
it's an 80-inch screen
and everything in between?
I think that's one of the really
interesting things about being
an entrepreneur.
When you're at a big
company, what happens
is you start gobbling up
additional things that
become your task and
your responsibility
as you climb up
through the ranks.
But when you're
at a startup, it's
more about firing yourself
as swiftly as possible.
How do you get rid
of tasks and hire
someone who's better than
you are at something?
And then you do that
over and over again.